[Music]
I'm 74 I'm also a teacher
and I'm from belgium
ivy sidaction television imedi datacloud
category kosinsky blue
[Music]
spanish and is also the directory sida
somos quattro de la noce as for channel
and artist intas est  death in iraq and
that we have a special mission
[Music]
participatory experiences democracy affirming
today Europe's feast this is the
end point of our work on the
conference of europe seen by the
citizens and this is an opportunity to submit
the results of our work to the various authorities
[Music]
regardless of event
st his teacher we have a
spin-off los primeros in business
the agreement is sitting back we work
less and son éric  to be
very emotional because it's the
result of many weeks of
work we can't say it's
over but it's it's a culmination
[Music]
[Applause]
let them all go
on  fired citizens  s drawn from the
27 member states that makes a total of
800 citizens 1 it is innovative
insofar as alongside the
citizen panels there is a digital platform
so there everyone can
participate
the goal in particular it  is to reflect in
a fairly broad way on the future of the
European union so it can be economic
social policy and it is about progress
this mandate finnair the orientations which
subsequently become
recommendations for the decision-makers so
it can be the parliamentarians the
ministers  in exeter
[Music]
it is in other words arnaud hacquart 0%
in the european market
put in particular mir hossein
moussavi spoke about tour
[Music]
mid-march have forms totally
in the hands of the last in order to
find out how
our  euro services
it was very impressive
to say to ourselves that we come from belgium a small
country and we laughed flat with all the
other european countries so directly
the dimension of beige went to
European dimension knowing full
well that my dna and my
Belgian gaming identity will keep it, but
I felt immediately integrated with
all the bones of
its
proposal
[Music] and
the church
wi fi credits
[Music]
discrimination and breaking in the
less important panamera and it makes fun of the
quality of life at
work
we have a bright personal future works
in the first session the citizens
bring up fairly general things
the second session in fact we take up
the big ones  guidelines to
refine them a little bit
and the third session
really consists of making
guidelines much more
concrete recommendations more likely
to appeal to the decision-makers
[Music]
velochrono salle izzo
process
for you to spaced disc
[Music  ]
how do we live
[Music]
so like on tape which cancels
one by one in front of the road and a big
bet more than three years to reverse the
court  be greenhouse gas
emissions without forgetting the shortage of water that
awaits us the climate it's now
or never at the beginning it was a bit
difficult with the politicians who
directs us is a bit like directing
a meeting when  we are in politics
so we had less opportunity to
talk to each other so there we had to
reverse the trend a little bit
and it happened very slowly and the
end result was really what we
expected  'we have our say
that we are listened to
[Music]
tiffany massive we go
after it is gone 02
g
[Applause]
[Music]
yes but if
you do
n't  'as organic just like in cannes france the
letters of publicity to the private
[Music
] fans of the
bag in gaza abou semiane indications
on the cake and
for me it was an extraordinary experience
because to be called at 74 years old
to talk about  the future of europe
it was probably not for me
that i saw  enais here but for my
medieval grandchildren the notion of care passed to
almont
questions a lot massoor pebbles
kerosene to fotolog anti-hamas mayor and
spylo to arrive where our pokemon
metal
oh
[Music]
years
m